because i know you were in the next
generation just like yeah i like next
generation
i had a voyager too i was more of a
voyager when i was younger
well we all know will wheaton quill
queen
we all know will wheat uh he is on
facebook this is his page
uh he god this guy i'm already reading
ahead and he's
so sick he is a sick person oh
so will wheaton here's just to show you
this is this is does anyone like this
guy anymore like even lefties this is an
official page so there you go this is
from him
um he posted this
and i'll read he posted a picture of uh
pewdiepie has a page on facebook now
like in one day he had already 81
000 people so he had a pay an official
page on facebook now
um will wheaton 23 hours ago
took a screenshot
of facebook recommending to join the
page you know facebook has like hey
you're on part of this page why don't
you like this page
will wheaton who played wesley
hi facebook hi facebook
on the one hand oh no it's gonna be like
30 thing okay on the one hand
i'm heartened to discover that you know
so little about looks like a woman by
the way when you
start a sentence with on the one hand
just like royce did there's a whole room
full of people going oh
it's grumbling it's like rand paul rand
paul in the senate floor we need to
spend another six billion
uh on infrastructure in uh michigan i'm
sorry our senator from kentucky here we
go
on the one hand god damn it rant
and on the other though facebook's a
real stack of papers
he has the little rubber thing for his
finger so you could turn the pages a
little quicker
just a little yeah um
uh hi facebook on the one hand
i'm heartened to discover that you know
so little about me your algorithms seem
to think that i want to follow a racist
piece of [ __ ] bigot
on the other hand she's such
scumbags on the other hand
[ __ ] you for recommending and providing
a platform for this race piece of [ __ ]
bigot
uh do you know anything about pewdiepie
no ah the people that have
come after him time and time again do
they know
anything about pewdiepie
i'm locking this post because it's
filling up with truly vile racist
homophobic misogynistic bigoted memes
and comments
from people who have flooded my page
with it too i guess
make the point that this guy isn't a
racist bigot
it seems kind of weird to throw a bunch
of alt-right memes at me as an argument
that this guy doesn't support their
alt-right hatred it's almost like
they're making a point for me hey
hey hey will wheaton
uh do you not understand
how the internet works like look
good example right those aren't
pewdiepie
fans do you understand like owen
benjamin's a good example
we were [ __ ] with owen benjamin
people realized [ __ ] with him got to
him
many many people that had nothing to do
with us people that didn't even like us
saw an opportunity and said this guy's
just such easy [ __ ]
he's such an easy target they're not
pewdiepie fans this is what you do on
the internet when you post something
like
i am not gonna have racist and
homophobic bigoted
comments on my page you were very much
going to get racist
picketed homophobic comments on your
page
endlessly that's what this is the
streisand effect that's what the
internet is
uh it makes me truly profoundly sad that
so many people seem to be entirely
comfortable with dehumanizing people
based on their race
and i sincerely hope these posts are
coming from teenagers who empathy hasn't
fully developed
i truly hope that they grow out of the
celebration of racism and dehumanizing
behavior
and come to understand that yes words
can be exceptionally hurtful to people
yeah i know one race the human race got
it will yeah
hot take uh so you going in what did
pewdiepie ever the the thing they always
bring up is the fiverr thing
which is so old which it also was a bit
it was a bit
shock comedy yeah it was funny
come on it was funny
well to anyone who wants to or feels to
need to
defend this guy this guy's words and
actions
as just being jokes please ask one of
your non-white friends
if they think it's funny when someone
uses racist language or racist tropes
okay you know what no i do have pl
yeah there's plenty of way see you're
deciding you see you're what you're
doing will right
you're you're actually doing the classic
subconscious racism you're like listen
these poor
[ __ ] stupid brown people
they need me to shield shield them from
you
and your hurtful words you see these
poor dumb godless savages
they don't know any better so i'm going
to assume i speak for all of them
because they're all just a big amalgam
of [ __ ]
mulatto mongrel people that i just
think all think the same thing so i
speak for all of them when i tell you
that nobody wants any jokes like this
that's the arrogance
let me let's do this because amazingly
for it wasn't
all we are we have a lot of people that
aren't white that listen to this show
please let me know is will wheaton
correct do you not like when we make fun
of you guys
does it bother you how many of you hurt
yeah all our black and jewish [ __ ]
fans and all you
females i mean really yeah why are you
here
yeah seriously why are you here if we
make fun of you
please ask one of your non-white friends
if they think it's funny when someone
uses racist language or racist tropes
under the guise of
it just being jokes ask them how it
makes them
feel then ask yourself why do you
believe that it's just jokes how does it
make you feel guys
uh know who else donates crazy amounts
of money to people who need it
people who aren't racist so i guess
somebody replied saying
you know pewdiepie gives a lot of money
to charities and he does
uh and why is will going
why is mr nobody guy who was the worst
part of star trek so bad that they had
to write him off
why does he think
he can go after people like pewdiepie
who talk about being
self-made you know what i mean talk
about getting no help from anybody say
what you want about pewdiepie whether
you like him or whether you hate
him you can't say that he is not a
self-made dude
he did this all by himself and he's the
most popular person on the internet
right now
but he's like no there's no way that he
actually
is liked though right are there lefties
that really
like see don't see through his [ __ ]
will wheaton
oh there's lefties that don't yeah yeah
i mean there's there's there's lefties
that that'll say
the but but will wheaton is is liked a
lot
a lot by lefties uh you have to
understand why though
because he's this guy's from star trek
and people i like star trek i've always
liked star trek but it was never good in
star trek
i understand that nobody ever remember
nobody's ever been like bro
put on that dope ass wesley crusher
episode
you're right remember bro nobody has
ever been an economy
like bro you remember the episode when
wesley
insert anything here yeah
there's no wesley stories right you got
a million riker stories
you probably have a billion wharf
stories
do you have any wesley crusher no tales
no nobody cares what talk about
i could do a [ __ ] four-hour show
about just wharf oh yeah
but like shut up wesley yeah shut up
wesley no one gives a [ __ ] about you
stupid